i have six equations here where there is
an unknown what i want to do what i want
you to do is pause the video right now
and try to figure out what that unknown
is so in this vid in this first one the
unknown is a blank what is this blank
what is this question mark what is this
smiley face what does this letter a need
to be in terms of a number what is b
what is this star so pause the video now
so let's think through each of them this
says 3 times something is equal to
twelve so let's think about what we have
to multiply by three to get to twelve so
three times one is three three times two
is six three times three is nine three
times four is 12.
3 times 4 is 12. so we could say that
the blank needs to be equal to 4. 3
times 4 is 12.
now let's work on this one
something divided by so question mark
divided by four
is equal to six
well this is the same thing as saying
that question mark
is equal to
four
times six or you could say 6 times 4
they're the same is equal to 6 times 4
which is the same thing as 4
times 6.
so what is 6 times 4
well 6 times 1 is 6 6 times 2 is twelve
six times three is eighteen six times
four is twenty four
so question mark so this is equal to
twenty four so question mark must be
equal to twenty four
write that down question mark in this
case is equal to 24.
now here i have 54 is equal to 9 times
smiley face so 9 times what is equal to
54. well let's just skip count with 9
and try to figure that out
nine times one is nine nine times two is
eighteen nine times three is
twenty-seven notice i'm just adding nine
each time
nine times four is thirty-six
nine times five is forty-five
nine times 6 is 54. this is 54 is 9
times 6. 9 times 6 is equal to 54.
so we now know that the smiley face so
smiley face
must be equal to 6. if we replace the
smiley face with a 6 and this equation
is true 54 is equal to 9 times 6.
let's work on this one up here
9 is equal to a divided by
eight
well this is the same thing as saying
that if a divided by eight is equal to
nine well that means that nine times
eight must be equal to a
nine times eight
must
be equal to a if i divide a into eight
groups and i have nine in each group
that means i have nine of nine in a
group times eight groups i must have the
total number of things so what is 9
times 8 well 9 times 1 is 9. in fact we
already did a lot of our 9 times tables
down here we could just keep going 9
times 6 was 54
9 times 7 is 63
9 times 8 is 72
so 9 times 8
9 times 8 is equal to 72 so we can say
that a is equal to
72 and if a is equal to 72 then this
equation becomes
9 is equal to 72
divided by 8 which is absolutely true 72
divided by 8 is 9 9 times 8 is 72.
b is equal to 20 divided by 5.
well what's 20 divided by 5. well
there's a couple of ways you could think
about it you could literally view this
as the same thing as saying that 5
times b
is equal to 20. so 5 times what is equal
to 20. 5 times 1 is 5 5 times 2 is 10
5 times 3 is 15
5 times 4 is 20.
5 times 4 is equal to 20. so that tells
us that b
b must be equal to 4.
b
is equal to 4. so we could write 4 is
equal to 20
divided by 5 which is absolutely true 20
divided by 5 is equal to 4 4 is equal to
20 divided by 5.
now we have one last one
we have star times 2 is equal to 4 is
equal to 14. so what times 2 is equal to
14.
well let's just look at our two
our two are multiples of two so see if 2
times 1 is 2 4 6 8
14. so how did how many times did we
have to multiply 2 to get to 14 so this
is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7. 2 times 7 is 14. so if
i wrote 7 times 2 is equal to 14 this is
absolutely true so star must be equal to
7 star is equal to 7.